- My relationship with tequila is
that it is my shot of choice.
And when I have one, I have five.
(mariachi music)
- Cheap tequila always has this
weird cheap tequila taste to me.
- Let's fucking go.
(mariachi music)
- Visually, there's nothing to go off of.
- I'm gonna shoot it because
that's the only way I know how to drink.
- Cheers.
- Kinda burns but I like it.
- That face didn't last
as long it normally does.
- There's more of a scent.
- Oh God.
- I don't want this in my body.
- It's not as bad as I imagined it
but the smell is horrible.
like this smells good.
- I'm going first shot expensive,
second shot cheap as hell.
- I have to say the second one.
- Me too.
- This is the more expensive one.
- Oh yeah, hands down.
This is more expensive.
- Yeah.
(mariachi music)
- This is amazing.
- Yeah, it's so nice.
- This is probably $80.
- That was smooth as fuck.
- Is this just Drano?
- Oh that's much better.
- Now that is a tequila you can't taste.
- This is good.
This is better than the last cheap one.
- Yeah.
- But this is cheap.
- God damnit.
- Yay!
- Damn! This is so good though.
- What is this?
- No!
- I'm apparently cheap as fuck.
(mariachi music)
- Smell it.
I just grew armpit hair.
That does not smell expensive.
- I might throw up.
- That was actually pretty smooth.
- It is a little stingy on the lips.
But sometimes you like that.
- Oh Sarah.
- If that's not Cuervo, I give up
all knowledge I know about tequila.
- Smells like throwing
up in the back of a taxi.
- There it is, there's that face.
- That's good.
- That's fucking nice.
Whatever this is, I wanna know.
This is really smooth.
- They're both bad, I hate them both.
- This is the cheap tequila.
This is the expensive tequila.
Without a doubt in my mind.
- I agree with that.
- No way!
- I hope to God that's the fancy one.
- Yay!
- I can't believe I didn't
recognize Jose Cuervo.
- This is Cuervo?
Are you sure you didn't mix this up?
- I like tequila I think a little bit.
You changed a life today.
- You know what?
Tequila makes me wanna hug.
- This is happening?